[Musique]
c'est le moment des derniers préparatifs
pour un retour dans un pays en guerre
j'ai encore des vêtements là-bas mais je
ne sais pas s'ils y sont toujours quand
je suis rentré je les ai laissé parce
que je ne savais pas exactement quel
serait la situation au moment de passer
la frontière
24 ans s'apprête à repartir en Ukraine
qu'il avait quitté précipitamment au
début de la guerre suite à l'invasion
russe en février dernier plus de vol
direct pour y aller alors sachant que
s'apprête à faire un long périple pour
rejoindre les bancs de son université à
Ivano frankievsk à l'ouest de l'Ukraine
je suis un peu heureux et un peu nerveux
parce que j'ai un long voyage devant moi
environ trois jours
après avoir échoué au concours
d'admission des écoles indiennes de
médecine en 2019 sachant qu'a fait le
choix de l'Ukraine pour réaliser son
rêve devenir médecin un rêve qu'il ne
veut pas sacrifier
là-bas c'est vraiment difficile de
quitter l'Ukraine et totalement
abandonner mon cursus et commencer
quelque chose de nouveau c'était
impossible j'ai beaucoup investi dans
ses études
sachant que repart en Ukraine alors que
le pays est toujours en proie de vivre
combat avec la Russie jusque là épargné
la région divanofrancif où il étudie a
récemment été touché par une salle de
missile une situation qui ne rassure pas
ses proches
mais sachant que tu exception sur les
18000 étudiants indiens en médecine
rentrés en Inde après le début de la
guerre moins d'un millier a fait le
choix de regagner l'Ukraine à patena
dans l'état du billard nous rencontrons
métabraza étudiant en quatrième année de
médecine son université se trouve dans
la ville de soumis à seulement 70 km de
la frontière russe lorsque le conflit a
éclaté il a dû attendre 10 jours avant
d'être rapatrier
[Musique]
lorsque nous avons réalisé ces vidéos
une nuit auparavant une explosion s'est
produite près de notre auberge après
cela l'électricité a disparu et
l'approvisionnement en eau a été coupée
pendant deux jours
à cette période nous avons été
confrontés à de nombreuses difficultés
nous n'avions aucune idée de ce qui nous
attendait
car nous avons vu des frappes aériennes
de nos propres yeux
malgré les risques pour sa sécurité mais
tape son genre repartir pour poursuivre
ses études
bloqué chez lui depuis huit mois le
gouvernement indien a refusé toutes ces
demandes pour intégrer temporairement le
cursus dans son pays la raison ces
étudiants n'auraient pas les prérequis
exigés pour suivre une formation
médicale ici
nous espérions repartir au bout d'un ou
deux mois une fois que la situation
serait redevenue normale et que notre
gouvernement nous fournirait une
solution temporaire pendant la durée de
la guerre
mes camarades de classe et mes amis
avons contacté les ministères mais leur
réponse nous a donné l'impression que
pour eux lors de voir se limiter à nous
rapatrier ici sans essayer de comprendre
ou de trouver une solution à nos
problèmes
avec des coups de scolarité quatre fois
moins cher que dans un institut privé en
Inde l'Ukraine présentait tous les
avantages pour devenir médecin
actuellement dans une impasse ces
étudiants refusent de se réorienter
professionnellement
certaines personnes pensent que nous
devrions changer de filière car cela
nous a coûté déjà beaucoup d'argent sans
être certain d'être diplômés mais cela
voudrait dire renoncer à nos rêves et ce
n'est pas facile à entendre
j'espérais devenir médecin en Ukraine on
Inde j'ai reçu des offres de collège
privé mais je n'ai pas les moyens de
débourser plus de 100000 € pour 6 années
d'études c'est pour ça que je suis parti
tout le monde m'a encouragé à devenir
médecin et maintenant j'ai l'impression
que mes espoirs se brise
plusieurs aspirants médecins ont porté
l'affaire devant la Cour suprême
indienne une audience est prévue le 1er
novembre pour entendre leur requête à
5800 km de là nous retrouvons chat shank
après être passé par la Pologne et la
Moldavie il a pu enfin toucher le sol
ukrainien à cause des récents
bombardements les cours en présentiel
ont été temporairement suspendus mais
pour l'étudiant en quatrième année de
médecine la pratique est indispensable
chose qu'il n'aurait pas pu faire en
restant en Inde
la médecine est un domaine très pratique
si nous ne sommes pas en présentiel nous
ne retournons pas les cours très
longtemps
plusieurs universités ukrainiennes comme
celles d'Ivano frankievsk encourage les
étudiants étrangers inscrits à l'est à
venir étudier ici dans l'ouest du pays
plus à l'abri la Russie c'est également
dite prête à accueillir ses étudiants
dont le sort est toujours incertain en
Inde